[Music]
this is happening
so this is an air strike uh alarm
i'm about to go into a bomb shelter but
this is very real
there's military personnel everywhere
i'm gonna go inside the ukrainian-born
dancer called the scene in the capital
city dire as he made his way to pick up
a bulletproof vest the 42 year old has
been working as a judge on a ukrainian
dance show this people that i was
judging some days ago
that are getting guns and getting
deployed to
defend the country i'm not currently
trying to leave i'm i'm staying here i'm
not
moving towards the border currently uh
it's i heard
nuns not safe
max's wife peter remains in the u.s with
their five-year-old son today she
praised former real housewife bethany
frankel's relief efforts for ukrainian
refugees in poland i spoke to bethany
today just moments after she was on the
phone with max
he said he's safe he said he's protected
like he feels he feels safe so that can
make us feel better how's the family
holding up how's his wife holding up she
and i have been texting and she seems
very nervous who knows it could go left
it could go right maybe he gets out
because he's a public person maybe he's
an example because he's a public person
bethany's initiative called be strong
works with the disaster relief
non-profit global empowerment mission
the team is shipping 10 million dollars
worth of survival kits to ukrainian
refugees in poland we have crisis kits
with hygiene and blankets and often
chargers and toiletries and things like
that amid those relief efforts joy behar
is being called insensitive critics
called out the comedian after she seemed
to complain that the invasion was
hurting her vacation plans you plan a
trip you want to go there i want to go
to italy for four years i haven't been
able to make it because of
of the pandemic and now this
back in ukraine hall of fame boxers
vitaly and vladimir klitschko plan to
take up arms we must stay united vitali
a former heavyweight boxing champ is
actually the mayor of key and vladimir
he's hayden panettiere's ex today she
shared this photo of them together in
ukraine they had an on-again off-again
relationship for years and have a
seven-year-old daughter together i hope
that western world is gonna watch us and
support us